okay or we let yeah we're live here we
go
good afternoon everyone my name is jim
manikan I want to talk to you about
secure coding I want to talk to you
about your responsibilities as a
developer to write secure software and
this responsibility is unfortunately
mammoth ly challenging who here works in
an organization or works on a project
where security is a really core part of
your development process where it's
really what what you're doing and that's
like five of you hey hey five people
high five to you five people in the room
like one percent whose security is a
core part of what you're doing the rest
of you I don't know I don't know this is
we're in 2020
you check the news out software is
getting hacked on a daily basis it's one
of the most destructive things happening
in modern society even worse than the
global legal drug trade in terms of how
much damage is done to society because
of our inability to write secure
software I'm not here to blame you as a
developer
okay the languages the frameworks
everything that we're doing by default
the web the standards is relatively
insecure so this is challenge
responsibility to write secure software
is an immensely difficult one but we can
do it with the right knowledge with the
right engineering practices we can do
this now this project on to talk to you
about this awareness list is from the
Olas foundation and I want to put a wasp
on your radar if you hadn't heard of it
already
a wasp is the open web application
security project in the u.s. it's a
501c3 formal charity it's also a
recognized registered charity in Europe
in the u.s. to become a charity we fill
one form out and we're charity in Europe
who we fill out about 5,000 pages
documents in like triplicate and
then you gotta get your name your child
Europe it's kind of tough to become a
charity in Europe yeah just a paperwork
burden so we're we're a real charity
around the world a goal were very
similar to the Apache foundation right
we're trying to promote web security
standards we're trying to promote secure
coding best practices and there's a
variety of tools from the Ola foundation
that are all open source the big one I
want to talk to you about
Oh a SAP this is a penetration testing
tool that you can point at your web apps
to do scanning to look for
vulnerabilities in the commercial
industry these tools range from a
thousand to a hundred thousand euros and
os has several free tools in this area
to help you look at your applications
for secure software but that's the
hacking part of security that's easy
we're gonna talk about doing it
proactively which means early on in your
software development lifecycle you
should be thinking about security hey
hey sir what's your name up front you
Hey
when in an S DLC should you be thinking
about security when do you think how
about like when the project's done the
staff security I'll slap some security
on at the end that is that is that the
way to go right at the beginning from
the design phase the earlier you address
security the cheaper it's gonna be for
your organization and more effective
it's gonna be so here this is the old
this is the OAuth top ten practical
controls we'll talk about security
requirements we'll talk about the
importance of the frameworks you're
using in third-party library
responsibilities look at briefly
database access and sequel injection
will talk about encoding and escaping as
a core control to stop injection we'll
look at input validation some
specialized form of it you got to get
right we'll look at the whole idea of
digital identity and how complex it's
gotten we'll talk about access control
protection of data in transit and
storage we'll look at the idea of how
important logging is an air handling to
end these are the business presentation
if you're advanced at secure coding
you're excused there's other talks you
can go to this isn't meant to be an
introduction to get you started and
point you in the right direction of your
studies for how to be a software
engineer that does security security
engineer and again my name is Jim Annika
you can find me on twitter at mana code
please tweet me up i'm a former board
member of the ola foundation i'm also a
board member of sec at dev in belgium
this is like a full week secure coding
course i founded the local moko security
conference in Hawaii it's a product
security conference and we don't do this
conference to make money we do it to
spread this knowledge throughout the
Hawaiian Islands and we're soaked it's
like Google sent like 50 people
we're excited there are very few
products security council's out there
it's a big deal for me so I found it
several these projects we're going to
look
the cheat sheet series to practive
controls the OWASP top 10 I'm part of
those projects where the book I've been
coding my whole life and I'm from Hawaii
and from Virginia let's get started
though step number one in any secure
coding program or application security
program let's define security
requirements
who here is agile who does agile
development
ok how many of you do agile by name
raise your hands
how many of you actually are agile like
you're pushing code live many times a
day kind of agility now you're those of
you who can push code many times a day
live production quality fast pushes
you're now doing like continuous
integration and development you're doing
automation you're pushing code live many
times a day you're agile who here can
only push code once a month because of
technology burden yet still call
themselves agile you are not agile at
all you're far from agile you're using
the name but and know what the modern
definition of agile is really in the
world of DevOps where we're pushing code
many times a day through automation
everything else is not agile so in this
world of agile requirements go away
requite like formal documented
requirements are a thing of the past
and this is this is bad for security how
many of you like a s like the main
standard document for first hearing
requirements is the ASVs standard 280
plus requirements we have to master and
very few of us have that level of
mastery I don't say that's in the
arrogant way it's just that we have
other things to do as developers like
get the freaking app to even work let
alone take care of the rigorous job of
doing it in a secure fashion every SDLC
document I've ever looked at the
Microsoft waterfall process here's some
some cess DLC lifecycle document here's
the agile Microsoft documentation every
single doc they you they say security
requirements is a core part of a secure
sdlc I want to introduce you to the
application security verification
standard what's your name sir you can't
enlist to a talk right no no it's not
just listen to a talk you got homework
from this this is a homework based talk
so when you get back home
you've got to read this document and
we'll be watching mark we'll be watching
you mark so you you ask gotta go read
the standard right this defines three
risk levels over 200 controls it's
similar to ISO 27000 four but with a lot
more tactical detail a lot of the
standards around software security
they're very high level and
philosophical and we're not philosophers
or scientists we've got any real
tactical advice to do security this is
where ASVs shows up there's a publicly
built standard it's a lot of the
standards i've seen in the world are
built behind the scene - no secret cabal
with secret handshakes this is all done
in public on github and a lot of
anonymous people provided comments that
drove this standard and there's three
levels of severity three levels of risk
for each individual requirement level
one is for every single app on the web
level two is for high-risk financial
sensitive data kind of apps level three
is if you're like storing billions of
personal records or infrastructure for
your government or building something
that shoots missiles that kind of needs
level three at that point right and so
all I'm trying to say is is that you're
probably on a team we're not everyone
understands how to write secure code
that's the status of the world today I
highly recommend you go grab the ASVs
standard grab that requirement list and
fork it to suit your company and now you
have an initial secure coding standard I
think a good place to start grab the
level one requirements for kit for your
company and make sure the developers
have the final say in which requirements
matter and now we have a baseline of
what security means like right now when
I ask most people what is security I get
these philosophical answers you should
only option only do what the app was
meant to do
oh the app should not be able to be
hacked and it's a developer that does
nothing to help me write secure software
it just pisses me off
right but when I say verify that
princely privilege exists users should
only be able to access functions data
files URLs etc for which they possess
cific authorization rules I can act on
that in some way so these requirements
all are gonna give you a really tactical
advice and how to do secure coding and
it's a great place to start what it
gives you is it gives you a common
definition across your team's of what
security is from design to implementers
to QA to security testers to operations
now all of us who want security all have
this we're all on the same page around
what that means when we care enough to
use security requirements not just to
build the list but actually use them in
our jobs day to day all right
we're talking about the OWASP collective
control sir you're late this is the
OAuth part of controls they already miss
number one it's requirements it's okay
thank you for being here we're now at
number two number two create security
frameworks and libraries to leverage
security frameworks and libraries
there's a lot of security controls we
have to build today we have to build
authentication layers we're gonna build
cryptographic solutions get TLS running
for transport security we need to do
escaping HTML sanitization all these
different controls core to a piece of
secure software and we're and you
shouldn't be writing to stuff yourself
we want to use a variety of open-source
tooling out there for example Apache
Shiro does really good access control
type of work in the world of dotnet we
have the HTML sanitizer a nougat from M
Gantz which is critical for HTML
sanitization which I'll talk a little
bit later
so I just want you to use a variety of
open source security libraries that are
well vetted that are that have been that
have been built reviewed and serve a
core purpose in providing security and
and more importantly once you grab a
third-party library you just picked up
massive responsibility what is that when
you're doing when you're doing secure
software and your team chooses to use
third-party libraries the moment you
start picking up third-party libraries
there is a massive responsibility
attached to it oh great bearded one
who's nodding what is that
responsibility sir
yes check the security of the library to
make sure there's known security
vulnerability in it and you know anyone
know what major hacking incident
happened in the u.s. because of
third-party library insecurity yeah you
know how like like half of the UK's
financial records got leaked because of
a US company getting breached did you
get back with AX permission to store all
your financial records
probably not UK citizens right but yes
so the Equifax breach definitely
affected your country a great deal
there's one of the largest financial
leakages of data in the history of our
planet is a big deal and first of all
when I was writing code Z the last big
project I did a few years ago this is
the vulnerabilities that showed up
through my project the first ones xx e
anyone ever heard of XX e before
who here is Schilling X M who here
accepts XML to their Web Services who
here excels XML in their legacy XML and
their legacy API services that you're
not working on anymore
now we got some hands right so I can
send one piece of XML to your server
that uses an entity that refers to an
external reference like like a file on
your operating system and in one shot if
you're vulnerable to xxe one request I
have your password file off your UNIX
machine or your earlier I asked machine
are similar in the in the world of net
since 3 5 and above this has been turned
off by default but this is a prolific
problem in software across the world
today and so this is what the
vulnerability and struts - not too long
ago led to the the hack of Equifax and
that can fax actually did a pretty good
job they they patched the majority of
their servers it's one cluster of
servers that was not patched that led to
an entry point into Equifax his network
which gave them month to look at look at
the systems internally after two months
of looking they found the actual
financial records they'd spent three
months stealing those records before
they were caught anyone know how the how
the attack at Equifax was actually
caught Equifax was using a data
protection piece of software
was inspecting the network looking for
security issues and this is a this is a
device that as an interceptor of
transport security
it has certificates built into it and on
clients of the of the people in the
company so it could inspect encrypted
traffic HTTP and TLS traffic but someone
didn't update the certificate in this
product at the beginning of the year and
so it was writing saying everything's
good and yet it wasn't seeing anything
and then when low-level engineer said
hey this ten million dollar product is
not working because the certs not
up-to-date so the update at the cert and
all of a sudden they see like all the
financial records of the world being
stolen in progress and they shut it down
this is when we go back and we more
further in history when our when our
kids are going through school learning
about security we're going to talk about
this incident as being a change a
paradigm change so dramatic it that it's
gonna lead to a lot of big changes
across the world it just shows that one
server not being patched can lead to a
global pretty nasty incident when you're
using third-party libraries you have got
the responsibility I'm looking at oh
great bearded one is we've got to check
our software stack every single day to
see if all the third-party libraries
we're using have an own security bug
against them or not and there's tooling
in the world there's a lot of commercial
tools I'm not gonna talk about those
right now from the OAuth foundation we
have the OAuth dependency check product
and it's there's also a retired net from
the open source world which you could
point at your dotnet applications to
check if any of your third-party
libraries have a known vulnerability in
them how often should you run this tool
to check your project for for insecure
third-party libraries how often should
you run this
before each deploy I like that who else
wants to play that's a good answer it's
reasonable by the way when Apache
patched this equifax vulnerability how
long did it take before Equifax is
breached
it was 72 hours 72 hours cougar has a
process where you're updating your
third-party libraries within 72 hours
that be nobody not even my teams but
this is the error we're in right now so
I recommend that during building you
check your software for third-party
libraries every single time someone
touches code if I start to build it
let's go run that one that tool and go
check let's check it at night when
everyone's asleep let's check it every
time someone touch this code and you
know what people even the best teams out
there who use these tools they're not
touching their legacy software with this
I recommend you on board your legacy
software that you're not working on
anymore
and run that every day to check for
third-party library insecurity in my
mind insecure third-party libraries is
the number one issue in application
security today a lot of commercial tools
that address this as well there's also a
great lad from Norway Ireland of tall
who wrote retired jas is scary this is a
plug-in to chrome and other browsers
that on any single page you're looking
at on the web will tell you if they're
using insecure third-party libraries it
just before you load this tool up and
use it steal yourself as you go to your
government websites your banks the most
secure most secure sites in the world
you're gonna see that they are lit up
with insecure JavaScript I personally
think javascript is a filthy language
that no one should use for any reason
but let's move on let's move on that's
that ship has sailed a long time ago
javascript ain't ain't going anywhere
some of us what's your name sir you're
not gonna believe this Sergey not even
close sorry so so whatever you just said
right Sam
he said forgot I was good to say do you
know what some people are doing you're
not going to believe this you ready
there's using JavaScript on the server
to build api's with oh what's that yeah
let's just move on I'm sorry about that
so so check your coat use some kind of
open-source scanner
or commercial scanner to check your code
base as many times as you can per day to
make sure your third-party libraries are
up-to-date from a security point of view
right we're looking at the OWASP top 10
proactive controls an open source
awareness project let's look at the
third item about securing database
access so how's this for a great
password it's uppercase its lowercase
it's a number it's got some special
characters it's over 16 characters this
is like a great password doesn't it how
about this what's that is that her the
perfect email address gym single quote
assume quote one Sigma naught equals
single quote at mana code calm first of
all is this a real email address am I
just pulling your leg here do you think
this is a real email address what do you
think sir you write you with the orange
shirt good color choice I like orange
yes you is that a really it could be
that's that's a that's a good political
answer I love it it could be sir no
cheers to you
who wants to play you think this is a
real email address or am I just pulling
your leg
what say you know what yes okay here's
this not only is this a valid email
address guess which other wonderful
property it has is live right now it's
one of my email address this is my
domain so if you're like I don't believe
you go ahead send me an email say this
is real I will answer with one word only
I'll respond and I'll say believe it's
real there's a real email address so how
do you stop sequel injection why do
people tell me it's sanitizing or input
validation if you run a validator
against this email address as part of
your security code and you ask the
question is this a valid email address
you do a lot of people do that for
security but what that validator say
what did what do you think Sam because I
true it's a completely RFC compliant
email address it's live it's also
compliant against the regular
expressions for email addresses defined
in the html5 standards this is a real
legit email address now that's all if
all you do for security is only to
validate this email address and I'll do
something like this here
database query just to look up some look
up a record and here's my lovely valid
legal RFC compliant and live email
address right now there's the final
query hey late guy hey what's your name
late guy the answer you hear link it's
okay it's all gonna be late it's I'm
here for you you're not here for me
what's that Holly Holly oh okay what is
this last query do if you see that or
one does not equal man encode com
what is that are you a sequel guy what
is that what is it what does that last
clause say or true when you add an or
true at the end of boolean logic what
happens that a whole statement so
whenever I'm asking can I select data
from this table every single row the
answer is true
and now with my email address I can
steal all data from that table so this
is this is a way we steal data by
manipulating sequel queries called
sequel injection anyone know how do you
stop this problem how do you stop
secrets out it out where I am I am
uncouth American rude and lewd I try not
to be but it's just be truthful so just
go for it use a parameterize query by
the way you could use a parameterised
query interface and still have sequel
injection if you don't bind your
variables so you want to use a
parameterize query interface and every
single variable you add to your query
should use parameter binding just like
this down here I don't care about Java
let me you want you want to see dotnet
you're all dot nedar's right I'm gonna
go off the rails for a second here you
see if I can do this quickly so I'm
gonna go to sequel injection so my other
presentations please forgive me I want
to show you the right answer from a
dotnet point but you're all dot knitters
right I didn't even know that until like
until really recently so where's that
net oh yeah that ASP who cares what
anyone do an ASP still
there you go here's parameterize queries
in the world of dotnet right we have a
sequel we have the simple command class
notice my query is one string the moment
I see a query that's built using string
building that's usually the symptom or
weakness that will point me towards
sequel injection so note here there's no
string building it's one static string
to define my query with an @ name and
app password is my placeholder I then
bind any old untrusted data into that
placeholder sequel injection goes away
this is because you're gonna tell the
database to build a query plan before
you send data to that plan and normal
sequel injection I manipulate the query
I change the query string which then
gets compiled and the database just runs
it if I prama tries my query the
database will will compile essentially
the the placeholder query and then we
send data into that query plan that's
already constructed and sequel injection
goes away and the performance of your
apps goes up significantly because this
compiled query is cached at the
connection level we have the same
control in every other major language
let's go back to our main presentation
here though all right be careful about
one thing though you can't parameterize
every variable look at the table name
here it see how the table name is a
parameter if your table name is a
parameter what does that imply about the
design of your code what do you think if
your table name is a parameter what's
the implication here about your about
your code design that you're taking a
table name for as user input hey Mark
what do you think about taking a table
name as user input how does that make
you feel mark a bit uncomfortable myself
as well what about what about the order
by clause being a column name is that
acceptable I think so I do that all the
time you can't always parameterize a
column name and yet we need to for serve
like doing sorting if I have a table and
results and I'm sorting it and I want to
redo that query order by a column name
is pretty common
I want to make sure I usually do exact
match validation on it feature by
feature level I want to be able to order
by by a list of different column names I
want to make sure the column name is
only
one of the names I expect and even
better at the UI level I'll use a number
for sorting which maps to the internal
column name never exposing my database
internals to the client anyway that
respects from the original
object-oriented patterns called the data
access object Dao or do Dao data access
object pattern where the earlier OOW
patterns about building MVC software all
right so one single injection using
something called a timing attack I can
use to steal your entire database so we
got to take this stuff seriously here's
some here's some additional resources
and here are some additional resources
and how to do query parameterization in
a plethora of modern languages Oh wass
top ten number four we want to encode
and escape data in the user interface if
a user interface on the web sees this
character it thinks it's code I'm
starting a tag here and if I escape it
and % LT semicolon it will display the
less than symbol as an HTML entity
without being code this is meant to stop
cross-site scripting where the attacker
can insert data into your application
that includes a JavaScript snippet that
another user will look at deny is the
attacker can inject JavaScript into your
application that someone else looks at
hey Robin is this dangerous yes it is
you get in this example what I'm doing
here this is an attack right in this
attack where's mom
there is in this attack I'm popping your
script has a URL to an evil website and
grabs a copy of your cookie we build an
image in JavaScript and then say image
dot source which will make a get request
to load the image and then actually it's
gonna send a copy of your cookie the
victims cookie to my server when I can
which I can use to hijack that account
so this is just one example of
cross-site scripting with evil
JavaScript I can just do your keystrokes
to face the whole site steal any data
from your page and and even worse I can
force you to make any verb request I
want get post put Pat doesn't matter
that's called a stored request forgery
so this is a really big problem
the way we solve it is we escape in the
if you're doing old-school templating in
the world of dotnet I recommend you use
the anti XSS library to do contextual
escaping and this is pretty brilliant it
has escaping functions for all these
different slots in a web page there's a
lot of good knowledge about this as well
who here is still doing old-school
templates for their HTML construction
who's doing angular or react or view or
something more modern like five of you
raised your who's doing what else are
you doing you're not using templates
you're not using JavaScript clients what
else are you doing we do like native web
code or some crazy stuff like that or
you're just you're not doing UI stuff
are you got other people for that I see
how you roll I see how you roll okay so
we have the same kind of so there's an
encoding escaping library for every
major language on the planet the goal is
before I ever put a piece of data into a
user interface if I want to display that
data exactly like user typed it in I
want to escape it in the right context
of the location on the page is it in
HTML block is it in a JavaScript snippet
embedded in my page is it a URL each of
those needs a different form of escaping
and that's what this family of escaping
libraries is for and just one more note
cross-site scripting is actually much
more complex than that this JavaScript
UI injection type of attack I want to
escape
I want to avoid JavaScript URLs from
user input I want to make sure I
sanitize when I let users author HTML
and much more right and so there's even
other forms of injection like command
injection that's an operating system
command being run through your software
maliciously by an attacker there's some
resources there and all the I have a lot
of links the goal is for you to like go
grab this presentation and read these
resources so I'll make sure I publish
this presentation out today check in
fact I'll tweet it out over at mana code
if you want to grab a copy of this and
go check my Twitter feed a little bit
later today wasps top 10 we're now at
number 5 hey what time am I supposed to
end by the
those of you who are meticulous about
time fork I got plenty of time all right
we're halfway through input validation
now we all know about basic input
validation what does that mean to you if
I say you should validate input what
does that mean to you from a technical
tactical point of view that'll get your
input what does that mean anyone hey
mister API developer you validate your
input on the API side of the house what
does that mean that what kind of
technology are you using to do input
validation type safety the common
technology that most of us used to do
input validation is a regular expression
right wait for every single input we
typically build a regular expression
that defines what good data is and
automatically reject everything else
this is called whitelist positive
validation like if if I'm expecting an
eight digit number for something that I
look for that eight NUMA eight numeric
digits and reject everything else
automatically this is not perfect
security remember my valid email address
is still sequel injection but input
validation is really common defense
technique it's been built into dotnet
natively since version 1.0 so we least
have it there but there's a certain
situation where traditional input
validation falls apart anybody do you
ever allow users to submit HTML tags on
their input for any of your applications
then the question is when users submit
input to your application comments blog
posts anything do you ever allow users
to give you HTML tags in their content
you say yes
anyone else you say yes how do you
ensure that that HTML is secure that
doesn't contain evil JavaScript or
doesn't contain any JavaScript frankly
money Houston it's on screen use an HTML
sanitizer and here's the sad story
there's no good HTML sanitizer in the
world of dotnet there's not the
one nougat right from end ants who
supports the HTML sanitizer he forked
this Java project written by a Google
engineer so I know I personally know
bypasses against that library to this
day this makes me kind of nervous to be
honest with you but we do have we do
have basically you build a policy you
define what tags are good and everything
else is going to be rejected I've been
watching this library I'm sorry let me
say that again the sanitizer really has
a hard time telling if hTML is secure
and I'm but it's easy to clean things up
so when you define the rule system we
shove HTML into it whenever it comes out
of it will only include the tags that we
defined this problem is brutally
difficult the person who wrote this
library Michael Sandel from Google one
of the best security engineers I know
it's had multiple bypasses against it we
fix it but I have to parse HTML 5 in a
rigorous way that's brutally difficult
problem so all the server-side
sanitizers have security histories
against them again the user submits HTML
as input to my server I run it through
this sanitizer and what comes out I
should be able to safely display to
other users we have a bad history of
getting this right on the server what I
recommend is you do it on the server but
also do it on the client introducing Dom
purify this is a JavaScript library that
frankly helps protect the home page of
the whole web Google search engine I
know you may not like Google because of
privacy issues and I agree I agree I
struggle with Google as a business
there's actually antitrust kind of
things going against it right now but
the people who work for Google my quest
like Samuel Michelle Spagnuolo Lukesh
why do some of the best security web
engineers on the planet and their work
serves all of us I'm a big fan of what
comes out of it when it comes out of
their work now this library in
particular is written by Mario Heydrich
from Germany from the cure for the
three-three team and this is a brilliant
library with the really solid security
history anybody here use reacted their
work any react developers like 5 a few
of you ever hear of that function
dangerously set innerhtml
that function do ya disables the reacts
escaping and puts HTML Raw on a page so
react developers if you're using the
function dangerously set inner HTML what
kind of life are you living mask how are
you living you're living dangerously are
you with me anytime you use dangerously
set inner HTML before you do that run
your content to Dom purify dot sanitize
you don't you don't even need to
configure this library has a really safe
subset or safe default policy around
what tags are okay and what's not you
HTML comes in you sanitize it and now
you can drop the results of that library
and to enter HTML or drop it live on the
page so for both view and react failed
to do HTML sanitizing in their library
their answer is here's how you turn off
our security and now how to sanitize
HTML we that's your problem good luck
and that that's irresponsible from a
library point of view you look at
angular I wouldn't wish that on my worst
enemy it's too complex to maintain in my
opinion but they have this security
built in really well this is built into
angular same team who wrote Dom purify
also wrote Google sanitizer and so we
need this Hana tiser for almost every
major language again I the the sanitizer
in dotnet I don't think it's as ver as
rigorous as it should be and I don't
know of anything else to recommend for
dotnet you're a dotnet shop here does
anyone know of an HTML sanitizer in
dotnet that's well-maintained and
rigorous beyond this this tool here I
don't know of one I keep looking for it
who's the head of security for dotnet
some Barry guy Barry Barry Doran so I
love Barry Dorn's so I was just curious
one day and I went and tweeted out Barry
Doran so I'm like hey Barry what HTML
sanitizer should I recommend for the
dotnet community and he starts attacking
me on Twitter
I caught him on a bad day or something
I'm a kind of jerk it's ok so so Barry
starts going after me because there
because the default sanitizer in dotnet
from the anti XSS library they
neutered it would be secure but it's
unfunctional supports like 10 tags and
it's done and there is no good library
out there and it takes a team of people
to make these sanitizers work well so
again I think the answer here is Dom
purify on the client and the HTML
sanitizer from Gant's on the server it's
a hard problem to bypass both sanitizers
not likely alright so the other big
problem in validation is doing file
uploads security anybody ever take
images from users as an upload feature
how do you secure how do you make sure
you're not being attacked by those
images there's a whole class of attacks
where I can build a gift that that if
you upload to your server and make it
accessible I can point to that gift with
an OS command and run oh s commands
against your server called a gif shell
there's a wmf files back in the day from
Microsoft's and so there are ways to if
you're poorly validating images I can
attack you through an uploaded image so
how do you lock this down I usually use
a tool called image magic and use a tool
called and using a technique called
image rewriting when a user uploads an
image to me I'm like whoa this is an
easy way to attack me so I run it
through image magic change it by one
pixel and save it image magic is a
c-level image manipulation library so if
I can load the image change it by a
pixel and save it and all three of those
operations work it's a legit image then
I'll throw away the original and use the
one that was that came out of image
magic just to make sure that the images
is legal and in general validating
complex file types like Microsoft Office
files is a real tough problem how do you
validate that an office file is legit
anyone know how to do that what kind of
file is a Microsoft Office file what
kind of file is it just XML just XML dot
xlsx LR is a big chunk XML this scheme
of that XML is like 500 pages long it's
a complicated piece of XML am I correct
Microsoft files are just XML everybody
with me on that so if someone uploads
like an Excel spreadsheet or similar to
your server how do you make sure it's
real a real Excel spreadsheet or even
better how do you ensure it's a real
Excel spreadsheet without a macro that
will do something dangerous can I do
something dangerous and Excel macro yeah
I could steal all data off your machine
game over so it's really dangerous so
how do you upload an excel spreadsheet
that you're gonna operate on or save or
distribute that's secure I don't know
the answer to this I literally don't
know the answer to this question I don't
think anyone does it's too complicated
of a file format so when I see a lot of
people do is they take it and before
they distribute it they say hey good
luck this might be insecure or they just
take it blindly check the file name oh
it's XLS must be good or something like
that so this is a real hard problem in
the world of Java I use Apache poi to
programmatically look at office files
and that's usually a few versions behind
the 8-ball I don't know what to do in
the world of dotnet at all and no dotnet
architect has told me what to do either
just proceed with caution this is a very
dangerous feature that is really hard to
lock down and again don't forget even
valid data can cause injection input
validation is not gonna save you we're
now looking at the sixth proactive
control that you should be aware of as a
developer the whole concept of digital
identity and so I'm gonna this would be
a great moment in my career Here I am in
London let's talk about US government
identity standards for a second and I'm
not expecting you to care about this
standard and many of you write software
that's bought by US companies too so
this is not so bad but the reason and
I'm not trying to point to a u.s.
standard I'm just trying to point to
some really progressive ideas about
password policy so what do you think is
good password policy the common answer I
get today is uppercase lowercase number
special character 8 characters or more
and this policy is doesn't help
us at all pardon my language I'm uncouth
I'm sorry I'll stop that's my one swear
of the day this nor traditional password
policy is useless and even worse
passwords as a sole factor for
authentication is negligent at this
point if you have a piece of software
that saves date privacy saves data
about users that's private data covered
by gdpr
and you're not doing multi-factor you're
in the world of negligence at this point
I mean that with respect only because it
were 2020 now we need rigorous security
if we're going to store private
sensitive data or as sensitive features
that affect people's finance or health
or similar we've got to do multi-factor
and again if you're not negligence I
want you to take that home with you
right so what is authentication first of
all we're just trying to establish the
identity of an individual user and how
do we manage passwords for for
authentication these days well let's
let's talk about let's talk about
passwords and password storage for a
second the first I'm gonna skip a few
slides but here is NIST really changing
their definition of what a password
should be they're saying don't limit the
characters or length of a password
except any unicode character for
passwords including spaces your password
should be at least eight characters and
support up to 64 characters or more at
the OWASP foundation we disagree we are
version of this standard in the ASVs
standard we cite 12 characters as what
your minimum password should be today
that does affect usability but and this
point is if you have eight character
passwords and you have multi-factor and
you have all these other controls in
place then eight characters is just fine
and I think it's a fair fair perspective
they're saying block characters that
contain context words here's one mistake
I made this is an older presentation
please forgive me I'm gonna I'm gonna do
this so the whole idea of a dictionary
word being in your password is
completely acceptable
I read the standard when I made this
slide the standard author was in one of
my presentations and critiqued me he's
and you're reading it wrong so I read it
wrong so whatever
so let's there we go we do this again we
got eight characters or more
I recommend twelve block characters that
contain repetition many many of the same
letters or numbers they're saying blocks
context specific passwords
well what company do you work for API
guy what's that
read books so I should never see the
word Redbook in a password what kind of
business are you what do you do at read
books so I shouldn't have the word
video-streaming read books and similar
should never be in the password probably
pick a couple dozen at most real obvious
context words for your business the word
password is also that also a bad
password because it's is there anything
including the word password that's
contextual to the input field itself
also check check against a list of
common breached username password pairs
this is an attack called credential
stuffing there's been a according to
researcher Troy hunt who's here at the
conference Costa he's real tall you'll
see him he's here at the conference he
says it's about 7 billion username
password pairs in the world today known
by attackers we should be aware of this
list anytime a user tries to register or
tries to change their password with the
known username password pair we should
see it in real time and blocking there's
a lot of tools out there's Troy hunt
service Google and Firefox have services
out there it's coming more common where
you can access this data set in your own
Authenticator also we have to handle
brute force attempts I don't like
account locking because if I know your
username I'll lock you out I prefer
throttling slow down the attacker in
some way don't force special character
rules upper case lower case numbers
special character throw them away and
that's very controversial but it's a
part of the standard
next stop using security questions or
hints how do you figure out security
questions or hints of a user so I try to
log in as Joe Smith yeah go to its
socialized areas work I wouldn't do that
but it's not as fair answer even easier
than that Facebook well what do you
think of Facebook by the way here and
here in the UK is Facebook like a nice
secure service talk to your friends or
are you posting all your information on
a public billboard in your neighborhood
is that one this is pretty public right
yes let's move on let's move on
no more mandatory password expiration
for the sake of it anybody work in a
world where they have new password
expiration every three months or
something like that so blue shirt man
hello sir I call you blue shirt what
does the blue shirt mean and star trek
by the way okay okay let's not go blue
shirt let's say sir sir when you're
forced to change your password do you
use a password cryptographic generator
to build a new 40 character random
password or do you take your previous
password and increment one of the
numbers by one it's okay we're in a safe
place is a good chance for confession
you do both okay
look let's play a game called security
confessions it's a chance for both
redemption and healing who wants to play
yeah okay who here with nerve force to
reset their password they take the
previous password and bump the number up
by one who wanna submit to that who here
is using it who's like I would never who
here wants to get on their high horse
and say I would never do that I'll use a
past or a generator every time and
that's how I roll who wants to say that
like five of you good the five of you
right here five of you high five that's
the right answer
we as a secure as a IT professional in
2020 or beyond my vote is you should not
know in your brain
any of your passwords they should all be
in a cryptographic vault some kind of
password manager that's well vetted in
the world today the biggest attacker of
password managers is a Google employee
Tavis ormally Oh he suggests to use key
pass very low-tech but great crypto
password password manager so your
mileage may vary but please consider
that and also again and even emoji
should be okay for a password one of the
big banks in the u.s. a few years ago of
security researcher was using emoji for
her security questions and it shut the
whole bank down oops
and so like she's not a support call it
the bank and they're like are you the
person to use emoji she's like why yes I
did
puh-puh-puh smile that's my past she's
like yeah we know you should our whole
bank down can you please like number one
don't say this on social media and she's
live tweeting the conversation they just
told me not to tweet this okay so you
you got to support emoji it's their kids
we're gonna use it so be ready for it
now how do you do how do you actually
store a password in the modern era
anybody want to play how do you store a
password in your database if you're
building your own Authenticator get the
security and DC security please remove
this person now what's your name troll
guy what's your name what's that
Dean you're such a respectful name for
such a troll so what do you store a
password sir so you're a pretty good
Authenticator
the users registering an account giving
you a password how do you put that in
your database if you care about security
which what kind of hash if you use md5
the right answer is shot as md5 sha-1
shot two or sha-3 the right answer no
because any of these algorithms are
lightning fast and for every five
thousand euros I spend I can do about
two trillion hash attempts per second I
will pop your password so if you're
using md5 sha-1 shot-to-shot 3 whirlpool
you are doing tragically insecure
password storage there's only three good
algorithms for password storage in the
world today
they're hashes but specialized one what
are those three algorithms no hands
raised or ever needed in this room you
just shout it out sir because I'm
uncouth that's the one I don't recommend
it is if I it was it's the number four
on my list
I would only use pbkdf2 if I was
building a US government federal system
it's part of the federal standards it's
one of the weaker of the algorithms and
I used to recommend it about a year ago
I just took it off my list at the
beginning of last year so it's a
reasonable answer but it's the worst of
the acceptable family I would keep away
from it I'd use it that bearded guy
right behind you said what did you say
bcrypt bcrypt
is the the worst of the three good ones
it's low memory input low memory
footprint it's available in every
language
it's a reasonable choice today it's
pretend it takes up about like 12 K or
six 16 K per run
it's a and there's a work factor to slow
it down your md5 sha-1 those are
lightning fast algorithms by design
we're beat crimped we're gonna program
it to make it slow on purpose you'll be
like a three or four second delay during
login but if I steal your database I got
to spend three or four seconds with
every attempt as opposed to one clock
cycle with md5 what's a good work factor
for beat crimped want to go for double
points you already won the new car
brand-new Ashton Martin will drive it up
in front a little later today you want
to trade that in watching hind Ward
number two yes you do so what's a good
work factor for bcrypt
hard question I wouldn't use the hash
cat team the team that wrote the the
major open source password cracker in
the world today I actually I don't know
the answer so I asked the lead of that
project and he recommended a work factor
of 13 or more and that should be good
for the next couple of years because it
grows exponentially 14 is a big hit one
of my customers is a very big bank a
regional bank that rolled out bcrypt and
used a work factor of 15 and it shut the
whole system down when they went to
production they rolled it back to 13 and
all's well again anything below that a
little bit too fast to be effective for
security so I'm gonna recommend again
the family of algorithms bcrypt s crypt
or argon to I which is default in PHP
any other algorithm for password storage
is going to be a bad idea
hey hash guy hey Dean the hash guy
before you send any password into these
functions hash it first with like shot
two or three and then set it into one of
these algorithms because if I give you a
giant password that's like 70 bytes or
more bcrypt will truncate and weaken the
password it's also performance problem
like if I give you a thousand character
password and you start B crypting it
it's a really big performance problem
but I want to support those giant
passwords so I hash it first sha 512 512
bits and then I shove those 512 bits
into
beat crypt we're factor 13 now I'm good
to go this is a recommendation by the
Dropbox architect PhD dr. Dave dot tuck
away in a very famous presentation for
2016 it's still valid even today and so
I'm gonna recommend the the the password
storage cheat sheet for more information
on this we have special publication
800-53 three I doubt many of you are
gonna read us standards but you should
read this it's not just about u.s.
standards very progressive in the world
of digital identity if you're a building
a login system yourself it's got a lot
of great guidance of modern attacks we
see against login systems even better
stop building a login system don't do it
use an identity provider auth0 paying
octa freaking a you're likely to have a
better security experience with Twitter
login as your open ID connect login than
if you build it yourself and I really
I'm saying this on purpose to be
dramatic but I mean it how many hours
has Twitter put into the login system
it's got multi-factor it's got push
multi-factor pretty solid not even SMS
got a push multi-factor they see mammoth
attacks at a nation state level some of
it just some and I'm gonna stop there
but um you're probably having better
secure experience if you use Google
Facebook it's Facebook Twitter or
similar login and an open ID connector
to your app and if you try to write it
yourself and NIST 863 B in particular
should point you into that into that
direction access control well that's
escalated quickly right I'm trumple note
on access control is stopped hard coding
roles that's basically hard coding your
policy and code and now I can't do
things like data specific access control
or how about checking if the user is an
owner of that message so a lot of
problems pop up like if I see a URL with
the message number like site comm
messages seven how do I steal other
people's messages just change a number
try out to add some kind of logic that
says
only show the message to that user if
they're the owner of that message and
role based access control does not
address that at all so we want to move
to capabilities which has been available
in dotnet since version 1 we're hard
coding the name of the feature or the
data they're accessing and have a rule
system in our database to make the call
if that could be accessed or not
roles are quick and dirty and they work
for basic easy situations but the kind
of complexity before us to do like
multi-tenancy data specific access
control it all falls apart in the face
of role based access control as a pet as
a policy enforcement point we should not
be using roles if they're in your
database for grouping that's fine
just that roles should never be checked
in your code ever in the modern era
nobody wants to hear this who's with me
on this point ok
this is move on again ASP roles we also
have ASP claims RIKEN hard-code the name
of the feature that had that point to
any additional logic I want it to like
checking if the user owns that data and
similar yes move on
so I also recommend you read than this
standard the attribute based access
control standard a lot of the u.s.
systems were built with roles and it
broke down in a lot of different ways so
the ABAC standard attribute based access
control points us in the right direction
to understand modern access control
complexity we also have in job that we
call permissions and in dotnet you call
it claims please use that mechanism
here's some resources for you around
access control let's look at C 8 protect
data everywhere how often should we use
HTTP in our work is there ever an excuse
to use HTTP for anything no no no HTTP
for anything it is a performance problem
and by the way HTTP is way more
performance friendly than HTTP here's a
resources on making HTTP configured
properly the best go look at the Mozilla
TLS configurator pick your server pick
your your utility it'll generate the
configuration file for you in every
server and cloud service except for is
which we shouldn't use so to move on by
the way if you're gonna do encryption
you want to use AES you should avoid ECB
mode you should Paul use got a lot
counter mode for storage you want to CBC
is well supported
you need to you guy v4 message you gotta
get padding right getting your key
storage right you gotta get your process
isolations for keys correct that just
gives you confidentiality if you want if
you want integrity you've got an H Mac
your ciphertext for integrity or use GCM
mode and you want to derive your
integrity and confidentiality keys from
the same master keys and you're taking
you called labeling and don't forget to
generate your master key from a good
random store saying good luck with that
no one gets this right ever in my
experience I've never seen a hand coded
encryption mechanism that the developer
got right it's too complicated you
should be using something like Google
tanked Dappy or one of the other well
supported well vetted secure coding
libraries I I'm a big fan of Lib sodium
written by Dan Bernstein University of
Chicago an activist in crypto incredibly
well built also where do you put your
keys put your keys in a key vault like
hashey corp or similar are you shoving
encryption keys in your registry stop
doing that you want to use a formal key
vault to store keys so if your OS has
popped the keys are still are still
locked down let me jump ahead here yeah
do some logging a couple quick notes on
logging just log at least four events
any authentication event any access
control failure any input validation
failure and that alone will let me see
have enough data to see to check out
what's happening after a hacking
incident the last note is handle all
errors I'll say this if you're doing
rest based development you should be
using HTTP error codes according to the
rest standard stop doing that HB error
codes are not even close to being
verbose enough for good security
I like PayPal's API error code list as a
good baseline for financial don't be
afraid to not do
asked perfectly rest was made in the
year 2000 by dr. fielding and security
wasn't even a consideration back then so
I'm gonna recommend keeping away from
HTTP error codes and instead use your
own more verbose error code lists
don't forget the AFVs standard the cheat
sheet series for additional information
on secure coding look at the OWASP
testing guide to learn how to pen test
and any questions for me please drop me
a line any time wait a minute
don't use any email address or use that
one there you go Jim at mana code net is
my great pleasure to be here
I'm overtime going to call it now go
forth and write secure code everybody
thank you for your time today
alright